so you've got the new fat standards
right new standards of weight and beauty
you also have new racial standards and
this one is a little
it's a little more subtle too i notice
with all these big viral stories going
around
the amen and you know bernstein all
all these sorts of things what's more
interesting about them is not what's on
the surface
what's more interesting is what's
beneath and this is certainly true of a
video that went viral it's
chenk yuger he's that guy from the young
turks
who just yells all the time and he's
very vulgar and that's just that's this
whole stick is he just yells and he's
kind of like you know the entire left i
guess that's their
their stick they just yell and say a lot
of swear words but chenkyuger
did the thing that everybody with a blue
check mark on twitter is
tempted to do at the airport when their
flight is delayed
you are so tempted to just immediately
go and complain on social media i think
we've all done it every single
conservative moderate liberal if you
have
any kind of social media network you
complain about it and then
you you hope that in some mystical way
this will get your plane to show up
more quickly so chenk loses it because
he's more
excitable than most people the flight's
delayed however many hours
and he starts filming the staff because
he's not getting answers and he starts
starts badgering them take a listen
we've been here three hours
uh and american airlines sucks
uh they decided for whatever reason to
screw everybody on this flight
it just frustrates me that some
industries just get to screw you over
and go
yeah you gotta fly at some point right
hey there's gustavo that's a tyt viewer
i
and i'm hungry and i'm tired and so
like you know me i get more agitated
when i'm hungry and tired
so look if you guys think this is bad
wait till if that plane doesn't actually
come from the hangar in 20 minutes
is the flight coming supervisors the
flight coming
supervisor you at least got to be honest
is there a flight
is there a plane you got to be honest is
there a plane
is there a plane where's the plane
where's the plane
okay so it's it's rude he shouldn't do
this
but it's actually kind of funny right
and he's it's not he's not actually red
in the face he's kind of making a joke
about it
and so i'm i actually i can't believe i
have to
sort of defend chunk uger for being just
as rude as he always is
but not particularly rude what's
interesting in the story to me
is that when this was posted to the
internet it sort of went viral
the the comment on it was here is a
two-minute video of chenkyuger screaming
at black airline employees because
flight was delayed
why do i care that the airline employees
are black
why do i why does that make it worse now
i suspect what's happening here
is the the viral post is pointing out
the kind of hypocrisy this irony of the
new
left-wing politically correct standard
which is you know black people are sort
of a special class really any
historically aggrieved minority who can
claim
grievance and victimhood is a special
class entitled to special privileges
and white people are bad in the same way
that you know women are good and any
kind of sexual
sexually confused person is really good
but men are really bad you know and
you see this in the slogans of die white
cis scum
you know or dead white males are
terrible and you got to take them out of
university curriculum decolonize the
english department which is very funny
because
you know for instance major english
writers just as a sort of by definition
tend to be white white guys because the
english people are white
and so that you always hear like
decolonize get the white people out of
the english department i think you
wouldn't
you wouldn't say get the italians out of
the italian department would you you
wouldn't say get the chinese people out
of the chinese department that's
decolonizing but this is a new standard
it's a new and
obviously identity politics is this it's
creating new sort of special groups and
special privileges
for for various people but i just think
it's
it's counterproductive for conservatives
to do this sort of thing
because i just don't believe it i don't
chen kuger yelling at a black guy
is in no way worse than him yelling at a
white guy
i it doesn't i don't think it's a
special crime
or some special offense if he does that
i do think it's
worse if chunk yogurt yells at a woman
than in a man because
there there used to be an old standard
called chivalry and men were supposed to
treat women
differently but i don't think that we
should
treat each other differently on the
basis of our race i think that's a far
more
superficial distinction than sexual
difference which is real the new
standards obliterate
all of that that traditional
understanding of things
and i just don't i think that it's very
easy
and actually feels good for
conservatives to just laugh about
this thing because you can either laugh
or you can cry
but i don't think it's going to help us
fight these new crazy standards
not one little bit i think it's going to
ease the implementation of those
standards because unless we push back
again i mean forget about jack ugler for
a second unless we push back and say no
it's not a women
it's amen that's the word you say and
you say amen
after we have prayer to open up the
congress as we have
for hundreds of years and and you don't
just get to choose whatever word you say
you say the correct word i think there
are going to be a lot of people who are
who have played this game a little more
squishy over the years said look we
don't
we're free speech purists right that's
kind of the traditional conservative
response to
these politically correct standards
we're pure we you can say whatever you
want
that isn't true that isn't true
conservatives have always
defended standards i don't think you
should be able to walk up to a woman and
scream obscenities in her face
i think that's wrong and you should be
punished for doing that
i don't think that you should be able to
walk out onto an nfl field and
disrespect the american flag i think
that's an incoherent act
i think to defend it on first amendment
grounds is absurd
because you are you're protesting the
country itself without which you
wouldn't have a first amendment
i don't think you should be able to call
a christmas tree
some other kind of name it's not i don't
i'm not saying you should be arrested
for it i'm just saying
we as a society should not tolerate that
sort of thing the left has always
understood this the left has always
understood
that there are always limits to
speech and behavior and conservatives in
fighting against political correctness i
think we just
believed our own abstractions a little
too much but this was true according to
thomas jefferson
this is true according to john locke
this is true according to
john milton the greatest defender of
free speech in the english language
wrote areopagitica
there are always limits there
necessarily have to be if this leftist
steers tumbler is a tumbler then it's
not a frisbee
and i can't call it a frisbee if i if
i'm really permitted
in society to call this thing a frisbee
then communication totally breaks down
and we have no way of speaking to one
another
and our reasoned self-government
devolves into a bunch of grunts
and violence and raw
passion appetite and self-interest and
increasingly that's the country we're
getting and the only way we're going to
be able to push back against that
is if we can actually articulate our own
vision and have the confidence
to defend it i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts